I walk into wacovia I just opened this
account two months ago so it's a new
account so whenever I would go in there
I'd say hey I need a $7,000 $6,000
anything over $33,000 they had to call
to get permission right like author uh
authorization so she's like okay I got
to go call I said no problem so the the
girl walks in the back I'm sitting there
waiting all of a
sudden a massive person reaches over my
hand and grabs my wrist and somebody
grabs it from the other one and they
pull my hands behind my back these are
two of possibly the largest Law
Enforcement Officers I've ever seen in
my entire life and they're
massive and they they handcuff me and
they say you're um uh Mr Sullivan you're
being detained we're taking you into
custody and you know putting you uh
we're holding you until a detective gets
here who are these guys is this US
Marshals or is this cops or what these
are sheriff's deputies sh sheriff's
deputies okay and as they walk me in
right as they walk me in the back
they're calling me Mr Sullivan right
they sit me down and by now
I'm you know the Secret Service are
looking for me they're they're calling
me uh but they were calling us JN and
Jane Doe but now they figured out who we
were and so now I'm on the secret
Services most wanted list I'm not like
number one at that right like I probably
was but I I we just found out I was on
like
on that list so it it's it's getting bad
so they sit me down and I'm waiting and
I remember thinking that the FBI was
coming you know I don't really know at
that point I couldn't tell you the
difference between everybody and then
five minutes go by and you know I'm
sitting there going what is going on do
you guys have any idea what's going
they're like we don't know we're just
grunts we just do what we're told so
suddenly this guy walks in he's probably
in his early 30s maybe he walks in gray
suit I think he looks like he's FBI he's
says hey I'm a detective with the uh I
want to say Richland County you know
whatever sheriff's department or police
department whatever and I was like oh
okay and he says yeah listen we've got
an issue wacovia wacovia wants this they
want us to arrest you he said that they
they're saying that you've got three
mortgages on on your house and I go is
that
illegal and he looked at me and he went
you know to be honest I don't know yeah
and I I and I distinctly remember
thinking walking out of here all I have
to do is convince this guy I haven't
done anything wrong he's already said he
doesn't know so he gets on the phone
with the head of wacovia fraud
department and he's tell saying this guy
is running what's called a shotgunning
scam which is absolutely right and so
what what is the shotgun it's where
you're you you close on so many loans
simultaneously they can't catch it
anyway they they start going back and
forth and he's on the phone he's like um
why did you close those three loans and
I said I you know what why are you pull
what I said it's not illegal I have a
first mortgage a second mortgage and a
and a home equity line of credit that's
perfectly legal and he goes and you can
hear the guy that's not they're all
first mortgages and I said I read every
one of those documents not one of them
said they were first mortgages and they
don't first mortgages don't say they're
first mortgages it's the placement of
the mortgage placement of the lean that
determines is their first second or
third so it's possible that I wouldn't
have known it certain that I could have
read those documents and not known and
he's like that's not true and he's
screaming and uh so I go yeah listen and
and he said well you're taking out all
cash why are you taking out all cash I
said well I mean I don't know if this
this sounds I said I don't know this
might be illegal I said I don't know I
said I mean I work for for a I work for
a um a labor company labor on
demand I pull out my business card you
can call so I'm like I work for labor on
demand and I said um we we hire a lot of
guys that like they don't have bank
account so the company pays them and
then usually I'll pull out money and
I'll I'll cash their checks because they
get charged like 10% of these check
cashing companies and I feel bad I know
the checks are good so I just deposit
them I mean I don't think that but I
don't I don't know if that's illegal I
don't think that's illegal like if if
and he's like no no no that's fine it's
that's that's a decent thing to do it's
not that's fine I'm like oh okay so
we're so he's talking to the guy you
know wovi is screaming out hollering he
says um uh he's doing that you know he's
going back and forth back and forth so
we're going back and forth back and I'm
just derailing everything this guy says
and at one point he says um he's
screaming he's committing fraud we want
him arrested and he's like I don't know
what to charge him with and he's like
you know he he's
saying these aren't you know how did you
know how did you he's like hey look how
did you even do this what I go look I
didn't do this he said I came to wacovia
I met with a loan officer I said I need
a first mortgage I need to pull out like
$100,000 I want to start buying houses
he go that's right you own another house
here too don't you I said I do I said
we're putting a new roof on it we're
going to build an addition we're putting
in a pool I'm buying one right down the
street from that one I said so I'm I'm
obviously I'm pulling out money MH I
said so I told them I need $100,000 they
said that's fine we can we they said
they could only get me $100,000
out for something about Fanny made
guidelines which is true and I and I
said so then she said I I can get you I
can send you to a friend of mine who's a
loan officer she can get you a second
mortgage which she did I said then I
told her she could only get me 100,000
or so 190,000 the other and she said you
should get an equity line of credit if
you're going to be doing like you know
um renovating properties so she sent me
to somebody they got me an equity line
of credit I
said I said you know I haven't committed
fraud I said I wouldn't know how to
commit fraud if you told me I said what
sounds more reason reasonable a guy that
works for a labor
company ripped off a bunch of banks for
over half a million dollars I said or
some loan officers got together and did
something illegal I said there's a
problem at the bank and he says I think
you've got a problem the bank and this
guy goes nuts and while he's screaming
he needs to be arrested this is fraud my
loan officers have not done anything
illegal they wouldn't do that he says
look at his ID his ID is fake his ID
starts with
000000 South Carolina ID start with
000000 this guy's in California he has
no idea so when he says that he go he
the the detective looks P looks at my ID
and he
goes listen he said this is a real ID I
ran this guy through NC I he said this
is Gary
Sullivan and I and I looked at him I go
now I'm not Gary Sullivan I go come on
bro what are we doing here and he goes I
know Gary I know and he
says I'm gonna take him downtown I'm
going to talk to my whatever Lieutenant
whoever captain and I'm going to fill
out a police report and I'll let you
know and he hangs up yeah I get up
they've taken the handcuffs off I stand
up as we're walking out with the
detectives as we're all kind of walking
out he goes hey you have ID do you have
a driver's license mhm and I went um I
do but it's in like Nevada mhm and he
goes oh that's right he goes you're from
Vegas and he looks at the two deputies
and they all kind of grin and I think he
ran me through
ncic which means he ran a Statewide
criminal database which means he thinks
I've been arrested three times for
prostitution in Vegas ah right I listen
I'm humiliated I was just like and the
grin told me every and I was just like
oh man and so one of the cops goes uh
here give me the ID takes the ID he goes
I'll check and see because I have to
follow him back in my
car so he goes and by the way my car is
is in the
name Michael Eckert so Michael eert he
doesn't have a photograph of Michael eer
right because you can't pull up
photographs from other
states so he doesn't have a photograph
but he knows that's not my car and he
asked me whose car are you driving I
said oh that's my boss Michael eer I
said that that's my boss and he goes oh
Michael eer I said yeah exactly and he's
like and I'm like oh my God so I'm
thinking he knows Michael eer knows it's
registered in North Carolina knows the
address which is where I was currently
living that's a problem so the police
officer or the um sorry Deputy grabs the
ID walks outside comes back I have no
idea if this homeless guy has a a
driver's Li license in Nevada I don't
know he had nothing on him he comes back
and he he does he have a valid license
he goes yeah it's valid and he hands it
to him or he hands me the ID and he says
uh he said he goes it's valid and he
looked at him he goes yeah well he said
it says he's like he says he's
5'1 like it was like 510 5'11 I'm
clearly not 5'10 or 5'11 and they all
look at me and I go fellas with a good
pair of shoes like that and they all go
f follow us Gary yeah I follow them back
to the police station Becky is calling
me on the phone screaming her head off
now I'd always told Becky if I ever get
arrested
yeah immediately go get me a lawyer the
lawyer will be able to get me out on
bond because it'll I'll be arrested for
something stupid mhm I said it'll be
something like trying to cash a check
you know a fake check or uh you know use
of something said it won't be all my IDs
are real so it won't be for for a fake
ID so my ident my ID won't be in
question and most most um police
departments and sheriffs at that time
did not run your fingerprints through
aphys so they didn't because they charge
them for that so they don't they don't
typically do it unless your identity is
in question mine wouldn't be I have a
valid driver's license or a valid ID in
that state so I go back she's screaming
she's like oh my God you don't
understand I just checked the I just
checked the um just checked the internet
the
website you are number one on the Secret
Service is most wanted list and I was
like I got bigger problems right now
they just held me in the bank I'm
following them right now I know and she
was like yeah get on the get on the
interstate go go I cannot go the
detectives in front of me the cops are
behind me they're escorting me to the
police listen she's like oh my God run
run I go look I'm not a NASCAR driver
like I'm
driving it's it's a it's a sports car
but it's not going to outrun a radio or
a helicopter like I'm not that's not
going to happen I know it looks it seems
nice I'm not that guy um so I was like I
can't I said look you don't understand I
was in handcuffs 30 minutes ago I just
talked my way out of them I'm going to
get out of this and I and I said the
worst that happens is I'll be
arrested as Gary Sullivan you can get me
a police you can get me a um an attorney
he can get me out and she goes I'm not
getting you an attorney I'm not getting
you out on bond I'm not risking
everything I've got for you because she
has all the money we've Got7
800,000 at this point so oh and by the
way she's not even in North Carolina at
this point she's relocated to Houston
Texas because when this scam broke fell
apart we were going to move to Texas so
we we were already moving
there
so but by the way just a small tangent
where do you store money in situations
like this that uh like when you talk
about 800,000 you have to keep moving
accounts to make sure it's not
accessible by there's FBI well there's
about 6 or 700,000 accounts but keep
mind I'm getting that out in cash like
there's no Bitcoin there's no none of
that stuff exists so my you know I I I
probably should have bought diamonds or
bought gold or bought like I don't know
any of that all I could think of is go
in slowly be patient
mhm um don't drain the accounts you know
fluctuate them like I was writing
getting Cashers checks from one account
to another so the balances were doing
this you know they weren't just going
they were doing this and then one day
boom they're gone okay got it so got it
so we got out like whatever we got we've
gotten out like 600 or 700,000 there's
still like six or 700,000 in the bank M
but I I'm not going back I'm done I
actually to be honest with you so well
look I I go in so I go into the police
station and well first she says if you
go in the police station I'm done if you
get arrested you're done I said well
then I better not get arrested I hang up
the phone the cop standing behind my car
MH get out I go in the police station I
walk in I fill out the police report he
tells me I got to talk to my captain
real quick can you wait he couldn't
leave me in his cubicle he goes can you
wait in the hallway I can't leave you in
the I said no no problem so I go and I
wait in the hallway in the hallway are a
whole wall full of on the corkboard um
wanted posters black and white black and
white black you know car thief you know
rapist murderer secret Services uh uh
Most
Wanted and I'm on the on on my face is
right there I'm like holy Jesus and you
know everything in me told me run bro
just just H ass right now right
now just go you you've your lucks run
out not that I even thought he was there
were so many I didn't think he was going
to see it m but it it just everything in
me just said run the problem is if
you've ever been a into a police station
you're not getting out of it you
understand there a lot of cops around
well not just that but they buzz you in
yeah you get in the elevator you have to
punch in a code you have to punch in a
code to get back out of the elevator you
have to punch in a code to get into the
next door there's like I mean it it
was it's impossible like I'm never I'm
not going to get in the elevator so guy
comes back up to the cop comes back up
he said hey Gary appreciate it no
problem my captain said we're good we're
going to wait for a phone call from the
no wa the the district attorney called
already they're looking into
it um I'm going to go ahead and let you
go I go downstairs he walks me out to my
car he said look do me a favor he's like
we we do have some serious questions at
this point like the district attorney
saids there's there's some something is
up he said I said not with me and he
said well just do me a favor don't don't
leave town I said bro I own two houses
here I'm not going anywhere M I said I'm
telling you right now I said W they they
up and he's like I believe you I
believe you said well he said whatever
he's like I hope you I hope they were
right I'm sure you're right okay so I
get in my car I leave I go to two more
Banks pull out more money but at one
point I go into a bank and like two of
the cashiers practically slam into each
other trying to get to the phone and I
can tell something's up like oh no no no
no something's up so I back I get my car
back out me kind of runs out and looks
at the tag number you know so I drive I
get in the interstate I go you know
Becky of course she's you know I'm sorry
I I love you I would have never done I
was just scared I
understand I go Becky sounds like a
handful oh my God
bro